to present the award for the best
foreign language film are two people at
home just about anywhere you can name
here from the sound and opera stages of
the world are miss Faye Dunaway and
Mister Placido Domingo
since 1947 the Academy is honored the
films of Italy France Japan Sweden
Czechoslovakia Russia Algeria the Ivory
Coast East Germany Hungary and Spain
regardless of the country whatever the
language when we watch a movie we watch
ourselves tonight's nominees for Best
Foreign Language Film welcome three
additional countries to the competition
from Israel beyond the walls in April
films limited production from Argentina
Camila a GE a cinematographic er srl
production from Switzerland dangerous
moves an African production contain
double feature a Nickelodeon sa
production
from the USSR wartime romance an odessa
film studio production
the winner is Switzerland for dangerous
mood
the members of the Academy eight years
ago you have honored me with my third
Oscar tonight you're honoring me with my
force however it is not I whom you're
honoring it is you distinguished members
of the Academy with this Oscar have
again encouraged independent producers
everywhere to do the kind of films they
believe in knowing that far away in
Hollywood there is an Academy whose only
criteria is a good and meaningful film
which may be remembered for a long time
thank you so very much for your support
for your recognition and above all for
your continuous encouragement